well we've had a confirmation of that
extension from seven days into 10 days
from the chief medical officers um just
to sum up
what they have said in a statement um in
symptomatic people kova 19 is most
infectious just before
and for the first few days after
symptoms begin it is very important
people with symptoms self-isolate and
get a test
which will allow contact tracing they go
on to say
evidence although still limited as
strengthened and shows that people with
covid
who are mildly ill and are recovering
have a low but real possibility
of infectiousness between seven and nine
days after illness onset
we have considered how best to target
interventions to reduce risk to the
general population
and consider that at this point in the
epidemic with widespread and rapid
testing available
in consideration at the relaxation of
other measures it is now correct
balance of risk to extend the
self-isolation period from
seven to ten days for those in the
community who have symptoms
or a positive test so a positive result
so confirmation there
from uh the chief medical officers that
uh
that that extension from seven uh to ten
days
will now come into into effect at from
today